the uk's medicines regulator the mra
mhra has approved
the use of the pfizer biontech vaccine
to 12 in 12 to 15 year olds now
it said the vaccines worked just as well
in young as in young adults and that
they were safe
for use let's get more from jeremiah
walker now in uh in the newsroom
and jeremiah this uh this new approval
what is that going to change
in for the uk picture well it's not
necessarily going to change
anything imminently because of course
approval and rollout
are separate things so the mhra say they
have approved the use
of the fisa biontech vaccine in 12 to 15
year olds
doesn't necessarily that it will mean
it'll be rolled out they've said that
among the 2 000 children that they
surveyed the children who received the
vaccine none of them went on to develop
covet
so we've got a statement from the chief
executive of the mrha which says
we have carefully reviewed clinical data
in children aged 12 to 15 years years
old and have concluded that the pfizer
biotech covert 19 vaccine is safe and
effective in this age group
and that the benefits of the vaccine
outweigh any risk
it goes on to say we will it will now be
for the joint committee on vaccination
and immunization
to advise on whether this age group will
be vaccinated as part of the deployment
program so as with all of these vaccines
it is a delicate and changing balance
between the risk
and the benefit we know that young
people are at a very
low risk of covid so what we can
extrapolate from that
is that this vaccine is safe for 12 to
15 year olds
not necessarily that will see the
vaccine in their arms anytime soon
and of course the new variants uh that
have been surfacing well the indian the
delta variant that's now
uh accounting for 75 of cases in the uk
we know that circulates more in schools
i wonder if you can tell us a bit more
about the data we've received on those
variants
yes so we've just received some new data
from the office for national statistics
and
it is not very positive these numbers so
what we know that in the week ending may
29th
in england one in 640 people tested
positive for covert now
that is up significantly from the week
before
when we saw one in 1020 people testing
positive for covid
we can go through the nation scotland
one in every 680 people have tested
positive
whales one in 1050 people and one
in northern ireland one in every 800 so
not a positive picture in really any of
the four nations but
england in particular will be a concern
and of course the question on everyone's
lips will be about the variance so
the way the office for national
statistics splits up the variants
is the uk variant and non-uk very
so what we can extrapolate from that is
that the non-uk variant is likely to be
the indian variant
which as you say is now being known as
delta now in england
the ons say that there has been a rise
in that
indian variant we know from public
health england that is now the dominant
variant in the uk so i think going
forward
the scientific voices that were
questioning the roadmap i think those
voices will be getting
louder and the uk ministers will have
some serious thinking to do they have
got some time
to decide on that next stage of the
roller and i think looking at this data
they are likely to use every single
second that they have